les élections municipales le débat
bienvenue dans ce débat donc des
élections municipales et communautaires
consacré cette fois à la commune du
marigot nous aurons une présentation
d'ici quelques instants par jean-marc
parti qui va animer ce débat avec moi
bonjour jean marc coma tous voilà donc
que dans quelques instants nous aurons
une petite présentation succincte un
clin d'oeil sur sur le marigot mais
avant toute chose que nous vous disions
qu'il ya sur cette table donc pour
participer à ce débat
les quatre candidats déclarés au moment
où on parle 1 ce qui n'exclut pas que
d'ici la date évidemment de clôture des
dépôts de candidatures d'autres
candidats puissent se faire annoncer
alors nous avons tout d'abord à notre
table patrick bredas âgé de 54 ans agent
territorial à la ctm vous êtes vous
représentez et vous êtes en tête de la
liste alliance nouvelle c'est votre
deuxième candidature pour une élection
municipale et communautaire
voyez très candidats à côté de vous nous
avons jean-daniel rhodésie daniel daniel
gros désir dernier loi lisez votre pour
moi merci de rectifier monsieur daniel
braud désir qui est âgé de 61 ans qui
est agent de la banque postale à la tête
de la liste ensemble bâtissons notre
avenir et vous avez été adjoint au maire
ait lieu en 2014 est démissionnaire
depuis peu de vos fonctions vous aurez
l'occasion de vous en expliquer tout à
l'heure un ancien maire également de
marigot avec nous en jav nerfs âgé de 73
ans professeur retraité il est de la
liste union pour la promotion et
l'animation de marigot actuellement
conseiller municipal d'opposition on
rappelle qu en jeu l'avenir a été
conseiller général entre 1998 et 2000 15
président de ce qui avait précédé cap
nord la communauté d'agglomération cap
nord dont il a été président de la ccnm
entre 1995 et 2014
et puis président fondateur donc de ce
qui a succédé à la ccnm donc cap nore
martinique et enfin pour terminer ce
tour de table joseph peraste 69 ans
professeur retraité mais en son temps de
la ville de marcq
go à la tête de la liste pour un marigot
forme et solidaire vous êtes également
monsieur payrastre vice-président de cap
non la communauté d'agglomération du
pays noor martinique en fondateur du
parti régionaliste martiniquais en son
temps sous les couleurs duquel vous avez
été élus en 2014 et puis aujourd'hui
vous avez eu notre affiliation politique
vous allez vraiment nous en expliquer au
niveau des mots tout à l'heure au cours
de ce débat bertrand voilà donc on va
parler d'eux alors d'ailleurs certains
disent le marigot dit d'autre ne met pas
le 2 le le devant marigot de 10
simplement marigot on va commencer par
là vous nous présenter cette commune en
un clin d'oeil jambes oui d'ailleurs
vous n'aurez la première tout à l'heure
ce ne sera pas décompté de votre temps
de parole
est-ce qu'il faut dire je vais à marigot
ou bien je vais au marigot qui veut
répondre aux désirs romaric vous vous
êtes plutôt par 10 en deux séries de
cette idée au marigot je dis je vais à
marigot comme je vais à fort de france
je vais à trinity par contre je dis je
vais à robert oui ou au françois
le au fond soit moi je vous dit à
marigot vraiment j'avais retenu l'autre
par contre si vous pouvez vous
rapprocher numéro je vais au bout des
maris ou mais pas du mal
donc voilà également en fait ma
tolérance accepte tout il y en a qui
disent ah le marigot aussi donc non je
crois qu'il faut laisser toute personne
libre de dénommer le mari koh lanta il
s'agit de vous donner une solution en
créole c'est simple c'est mon cas les
marinas la question de à eau etc
et puis les habitants c'est marie
gauthey marigot tnc cette pause
internationale sont pas des conteneurs à
rome j'ai dit ça à l'intention de nos
chronos mercredi soir kobe niger joseph
de la rédaction de martinique la
première avec à ses côtés des yeux qui
kelly et frédéric macherot la rédactrice
en chef
d'ailleurs on a le même débat pour cette
excuse pour cet esprit à 7,8 fermons la
parenthèse marigot où le frigo pour
hausse et celles qui ont oublié qu'ils
ne savent pas où se situer bien il fit
suffit d'aller sur la côte nord
atlantique où la côte nord-est
et puis on une fois qu'on a dépassé
cette marie et avant d'arriver aux
lorrains comptons à marigot comptant au
marigot
c'est l'une des communes
moins peuplée de la de cap nom de la
communauté d'agglomération la commune
est représentée par un délégué sous les
54 membres du bureau communautaire de
cap nau son conseil municipal va compter
23 aeio mars prochain puisque marigot
est passé sous la barre des 3500
habitants il y avait un peu moins de
3200 habitants au 1er janvier 2020 selon
l'insee plus de 3500 2012 an pendant
cinq ans la population est abaissée de
372 personnes
c'est au-dessus de la moyenne
martiniquaise la martinique perd 0,8
pour cent de la population marie gosset
2,2 pour cent donc c'est quand même
important et je rappelle johnny shih tzu
la population 60 ans depuis le
recensement de 1961 la population est
passée d'environ 3500 a aujourd'hui un
peu plus de 3000 de mode histoire mais
très rapide la paroisse a été érigée en
1889 je ne vous apprends rien messieux
mais en fait tout le monde n'habite pas
encore à marigot toutes celles et tous
ceux qui nous qui nous écoutent
au début de la colonisation toute cette
région de marigot y compris qu'ils
étaient peuplés étant essentiellement
par les kalina go ou les caraïbes ont
fait un plus
qu'ils fassent ils les français ont
réussi à les à les en chasser en 1658 se
sont implantés durablement et ont
commencé l'exploitation de denrées
tropicales notamment le tabac lundi go
et surtout plus tard la canne à sucre
je rappelle que marigot une commune
assez étendue plus de 2000 hectares
alors avoir pour celles et ceux qui
veulent visiter mon l'église récemment
rénové peut-être qu'on en parlera dans
le débat qui à la belle plage de
lancieux en compte y est prisé de
certains chauffeurs tout l'orient pays
en passant par domino une balade une
visite fortement conseillée et puis
l'habitation la grande chez l'une des
plus anciennes plantations sucrières de
la région les plumes parmi les plus
florissantes
à voir également et enfin quelques
personnalités où on oublie un peu que
victor à nice et plasticien est natif de
marigot il a fait beaucoup pour le
rayonnement de la ville
aujourd'hui encore eugène mona était
natif de marigot est en fait plus jeunes
de louche
le musicien bien connu en pratiquant
notamment de la clarinette voilà de
manière très arbitrer en quelques clins
d'oeil sur marigot alors vous l'avez pas
dit jean-marc mais je sais que vous
auriez voulu donc voilà
il ya une figure comme un politique
importante oui marigot un ancien maire
qui a failli égaler le record de
messagerie de longévité à la tête de la
mairie font dire quelques mots comme
celle renard qui a été élu en 1947
c'était à l'époque le benjamin des
maires de france à l'âge de 23 ans élu
sous l'étiquette du parti communiste
après il a changé d'orientation
politique on le sait il est devenu
gaulliste et puis à la fin de sa de sa
vie il a créé la martinique avant tout
un mouvement qui m'avait fait dissidence
en quelque sort michel renard qui
restait à la tête de la ville 48 ans toi
qui a marqué un espace et l'avenir
puisque c'est vous qui l'avait battu en
1995 qui a manqué d'éthique et social de
la ville de marigot voilà eh bien place
maintenant aux débats le tirage au sort
vous a désigné patrick bredas pour
répondre à la première question alors
nous avions prévu avec jean-marc de
parler d'abord peut-être des pourquoi
pas des finances de la situation
financière de la commune et puis nous
sommes ravisés nous avons dit bon la vie
quotidienne des habitants et des
habitants de marigot au cours de ces
dernières années a été aussi beaucoup
marqués par l'invasion des algues
sargasse je sais que vous habitez le
marigot patrie bredas est ce que vous
faites partie de ceux justement qui ont
été fortement importunés par ce
phénomène mais surtout estimez-vous en
l'occurrence que la municipalité a saisi
le problème comme il le fallait et a pu
apporter quelques solutions
alors tout d'abord même si évidemment la
municipalité n'est pas à l'origine de
l'arrivée des algues en avant précise
quand même
alors tout d'abord permettez moi de vous
remercier mon team et au mien pour cette
invitation
permettez moi aussi de saluer l'ensemble
des candidats ici présents et bien
entendu les auditrices et les auditeurs
de marigot qui nous occupe sans doute
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'attention alors
je me sens particulièrement bien à
l'aise ici pour en débattre ce soir
parce que les candidats qui sont ici ce
sont des marais gaudin on se connaît on
se croise pour certains on a travaillé
ensemble on a des relations sur le
marigot
entendu nous avons chacun une vision
pour notre commune mais l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir la vision d'accor est la bonne
de préférence
maintenant vous m'interrogez soul et
s'agace forcément surtout surtout oui
oui des argales la gestion des sargasses
à la gestion oui donc les conséquences
les camps s'est crashé alors les sagas
c'est un phénomène naturel
forcément le prochain maire a aussi à
faire face aux sags as moi ce qui me
concerne en tant que margotin forcément
je suis impactés par ce phénomène parce
que je suis président d'une association
on avait une place où on faisait de de
l'animation ça nous faisons un petit peu
un amputé
nous nous nos manifestations
j'ai des gens des maillotins des amis
des parents qui habitent eux un projet
audio de côtière bien entendu il en
souffre maintenant sur la gestion
puisque c'est là que vous mettez à vous
interroger
oui j'estime que le met en place il a
essayé de faire ce qui était possible de
faire maintenant
alors là où je dis attention attention
quand on se dit candidat comme moi ou
comme les autres qui sont là comme en
métropole comme en martinique
s'agace cyclone mauvais temps attends tu
as des as avalanche
on doit se tenir prêt à tout ça parce
que ce sont des choses qui existent
quand on sait qu'en martinique
nous avons des risques multifactorielle
que ce soit vis sous la mine mais je
veux une fille comme ça m'agace parce
qu'il faut passer la parole aux
alençonnais s'agace écouter la gestion
la gestion isr la gestion jeudi que le
maire en place a tenté de faire ce
qu'ils pouvaient maintenant ce que je
dis avec une petite parenthèse je pense
que les sagas sont servis beaucoup pour
cacher un certain nombre de choses parce
que il ya beaucoup de choses qui n'ont
pas pu être fait par par rapport
sargasses mais là on aura le temps d'en
débattre
il ya une chose aussi sous lequel je
voulais avons un chiffre précis ce soit
je le dire monsieur le maire c'est ce
fameux truc sorte que tout le monde
connaît sous le nom de sargasses ce
fameux tout sur jouez bien en tant que
citoyen et impose un citoyen imposable
de marigot qu'on est le plus de ce
fameux tout sauf une fois où tout est la
participation communale
parce qu'il en va quand même
dans nos impôts voilà c'est l'occasion
rêvée pour monsieur le maire joseph
ferrasse de répondre à cette question en
particulier puis de manière plus
générale sur la gestion de ce phénomène
puisque la municipalité a acquis une
machine appareil un dispositif pour
ramasser ces algues où on est on est on
y voit aujourd'hui où en êtes vous oui
tout à fait bonsoir monsieur je veux
former chez les candidats je salue les
maris goutines les émails boutin et je
vais donc arriver à tout de suite essayé
de répondre à la question de sa gas et
de la gestion monsieur le candidat
bouddha cela dit parfaitement clair 1
c'est un phénomène qui n'était pas prévu
et que d'autres ne peut pas non plus
imaginer la dimension lorsque vous savez
il ya des moments où la bd ça vacille à
d'autres moments il y en a pas là des
moments il y en a beaucoup et d'autres
moments bien mince alors nous avons pu
gérer un peu comme nous pouvions nous
étions dix communes comme ça impacte et
ce sont les communes de la côte
atlantique et je crois savoir qu'en la
matière le maire du marigot s'est très
bien débrouillé puisque il a été le
premier est pourtant une toute petite
commune de 2500 âmes de 2500 je dis bon
moins de 500 maintenant habitants il a
été le premier à bénéficier de fonds est
aussi le premier à s'être équipés dotés
de machines alors pour le marigot il
s'agit pas d'un sarda tort mais il
s'agit d'un truc ce haut de sa 14e la
ville du robert alors vous estimez que
ça a été efficace d'avoir eu recours
l'acquisition de cette de cet engin de
cet outil en quelque sorte de cette
machine est donc ça a permis de réduire
le phénomène est de réduire les
inconvénients causés aux habitants
habitants que vous savez avant d'adopter
les communes de quoique ce soit il y
avait des services d'état là des halles
rs la préfecture les services d'état qui
se penchait régulièrement pour étudier
les modalités d'intervention sur les
différentes communes pour le marigot
c'est assez spécial vous avez des
communes comme le diamant comme le
vauclin qui ont des kilomètres de plages
de sable au marigot on n'a pas eu m
enfin il veut parler du bourg nous avons
une petite plage de sable à charpentier
qui n'est pas utilisée puisque la mégane
est dangereuse en ces lieux et puis le
bout du marigot où il s'agit de
l'enrochement dit non mais c'est le mans
vous expliquer trouver mais
d'enrochement d'accord c'est à dire
c'est ça que j'appelle donc les soldats
arrivent au marigot il faut pouvoir les
enlever
eh bien on utilisait ce qu'on appelait
un tractopelle une machine à grand bras
il y avait les plus grands bras en
martinique il y en a que comme ça donc
j'utilise ces machines qui pouvaient 2-2
le sont vraiment arrivés à 30 ou 40
mètres à peu près dans l'océan
donc ce qui fait qu'il pleuve belle les
sardanes et la commune avec un camion et
une pelleteuse parce qu'on nous a
financé aussi pour une pelleteuse nous
enlevions les sardes s après nous avions
un plan d'eau où les marins pêcheurs
donc là c'est plat pas devant rien du
tout le ne bouge pas donc les sardes as
reste et pour les enlever
il fallait de cette machine en fibres
c'est une machine amphibie c'est à dire
qui porte ce qui peut travailler
si vous avez fait ça au moindre coup
combien ça a coûté à la ville et combien
c'est la question que posait le registre
et l'administré paraît il ya deux ans
raison parce que j'ai réussi à remonter
beaucoup il a raison alors j'entends
appauvrissement de choses par des gens
mêmes qui ont été maires pour sortir des
trucs courriel en ce qui concerne j'ai
emmené donc là le tableau de financement
la machine a coûté 100 mille euros nous
avions la detr l'état qui intervient
pour 55% donc 55000 euros
nous avons la ctm qui intervient à
hauteur de 20 pour cent vingt mille
euros
nous avons quatre no15 books en 15000
euros et la ville du marigot intervient
à hauteur de 10 pour cent dix mille
euros ça fait un total de cent mille
euros
voilà donc les hommes candidats les
informations sur cela monsieur l'avenir
un jeu l'avenir vous vous contestez ces
chiffres c'est d'abord d'abord saluer
mangou ten les mâles goûte un mélo duke
et béret lamoly première chose
évidemment je suis pas du tout la
gratuité reste du temps qu'il a fallu
juin l'ancien mais j'ai eu à gérer les
sargasses passe a commencé depuis 2011
mais ça ne fait pas une quantité aussi
important c'est très clair maintenant
c'est une gestion hasardeuse et
approximative s'est affairée pouvait
faire mieux quand monsieur perez sur
contredit alors je voudrais savoir
vraiment un super as
quant aux vous fini n'est ce pas de
tromper les paras gaudin après les
élections de 15 mars quand vous ajoutez
définitivement le maintien n'est pas
encore là attendez les italiens ne me
posais une question je voudrais je vous
dis que vous il faudra que vous puis
charles été ou seront payés margutti
après le 15 mai c'est l'avenir alors on
met en quoi estimez-vous qu'il annonce
comme arrigo sacchi des machines
adaptées inadaptée complètement à gré
des compétences aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on voit bien le résultat la
machine égale
c'est pas parce qu'il n'ya pas les
sargasses c'est tout municipal mais oui
monsieur principe merci oui c'est parler
alors heureusement qui a pas de sergas
heureusement parce qu'on serait
complètement dénudé par rapport à ça
monsieur peyras je pense qu'ils vont
dire la machine ne fonctionne pas non
elle est peut-être remiser pour un
moment il n'y a pas de gêne pas elle ne
fonctionne pas simplement sur le plan de
financement
la machine était mis à l'eau début juin
le pôle ne finance pas été bouté à le 19
ou 2019 alors évidemment prétexte de
l'urgence de la cik là il ya quand même
un prétexte c'est un peu je dis bien
peut-être j'ai pas dit c'est vraiment
une bonne raison c'est un prétexte
puis il ya tout est prétexte à la
gestion commune donc par conséquent le
plan de financement on a annoncé la ctm
dunoise cap no denwa sais ce que c'est
ce que les partitions et oui mais c'est
le plan des finances pas mais après
l'aube 10 % c'est sur la comète j'ai
refusé un but aux huiles 63 % de
participation de la ville pour souhaiter
pouget qui nous ont eu lieu à 62 ou 63
ans à mon dernier doit tout à l'heure
mais d'accord je dis très clairement
c'est une gestion hasardeuse et que
cette machine là elle est inadaptée à la
situation et que ce n'est pas pour
prétexte de 10 en plus la première
commune à avoir pour pouvoir acheter une
machine de ce type là à quel prix et la
commune à payer 50% de ce que lui même a
dit vous n'êtes pas d'accord même sur un
chiffre qu'il avance la répartition
quand même faut dire la vérité aux
marionnettes veille à la mêlée vérité
avec moi je moi je ne sais pas il a des
documents monsieur picasso et après on
en compte mais je dis qu'il a payé 9000
euros mois dit monsieur monsieur
rhodésie aussi et conseil municipal il
faut bien qu'ils en compte dans la
population
moi je suis pas au conseil municipal
j'ai fait ce choix maintenant j'aime les
formes non censurée par ses jambes mais
la parole la parole sur twitter mercredi
oui gestionnaire j'ai pas demandé
alors monsieur le raid à celui habite
marigot donc qu'il a pu être importunées
par ces algues sargasse qui habite parmi
vous au marigot
moi j'habite au mari de vous inviter les
amis des marigots jana vous habitez
sainte marie donc vous n'avez pas été
c'est non
la ville de sainte marie était d'accord
à niveau ou au diamant marigot paris où
j'habitais centrale et aussi parce que
tout le monde les yeux doux il n'en est
rien mais jacques marrigues au new
jersey soit patient hauteur à cette
manne qui n'ont pas été très touché par
ce bon on y va donc c'était un petit
tour de table pour savoir si vous passez
par ces algues sargasse alesi d'abobo
soir à vos auditeurs et mon équipe et
moi nous vous remercions de nous avons
invité à 7 à ce débat qui j'espère sera
de bonne tenue
pour toute la population on leur doit sa
devront effectivement les services de
commencer en 2011
c'est pas 2015 quand on quand nous
sommes dans l'idéal on n'a pas dit que
sa personnalité par exemple que des crs
commencer en 2011
et puis des services et une pas un
problème est particulière uniquement
marigot communal c'est un problème qui
est et au niveau départemental et il
faudra peut-être que tout le monde se
mouiller un que la rse se mouiller un
peu plus que ça parce que nos amis de au
monde moi j'habite chez repenti j'ai eu
les saccages et l'odeur des sargasses et
puisque il ya une poche juste en dessous
de chez moi donc j'ai été impacté par
l'odeur mais on n'a pas pu enlever cette
poche avec la machine avant des
commandes et par là ne sait pas que ces
vaches et brun plainte devait passer sur
ce point que de toute façon les gens de
deux romans alors je les plains parce
qu'ils ont été dites nous comment vous
estimez que mais je ne vais pas y
arriver aussi vite
oui je vais parler très vite dans du
cours donc je dis qu'il faut il faut que
ce soit que tout le département
s'implique dans dans ce problème de sa
dette
donc c'est vrai au début il ya eu un peu
et de surtout au niveau préfectoral où
on disait on tombe vite pour monter
quelque chose at-elle communes les
communes des plus précis pour n'est-elle
pas des appareils d appareils etc
le problème qui se posait pour le
marigot c'est le problème du truc sort
que c'est de ce que vous voudrez pas des
particulièrement moi je pense que la
gestion générale a été bonne si on
pouvait pas faire beaucoup plus sur
l'ensemble de la gestion générale
d'autant plus que en lever les sargasses
le problème qui se pose c'est pouvoir
les stocker et c'est un gros problème
parce qu'il faut déstocker avec une
épaisseur de 10 cm
ok pour que ça fasse pas de gaz c'est à
droite que dans tous les détails
effectivement que c'est un problème qui
est un petit peu compliqué que quand ça
va arriver quel que soit l'élu qui sera
là il y aura ce travail-là faire
chercher des points pour collecter et
sait que ce sera difficile pour
n'importe quel mars prochain ce sont des
filles
ce sera difficile d'autant plus qu'il
n'a pas encore il ya des appels à
projets et en a pas on croise le projet
wii à passer de sales gaz pour
satisfaire les projets etc
mais l'autre point au niveau du tri sont
mais moi je suis désolé c'est un
appareil qui n'est pas adaptée du tout
et que le service technique en avait
parlé ça a fait débat c'est un appareil
si vous allez sur internet votre beau
tapis truc ça c'est un appareil qui est
fait pour les deux pôles eau douce
c'est cet appareil où on est roi les
rivières les centraux des rivières en et
c'est donc c'est pas étonnant que nous
sommes les seuls à les avoir à la voix
personnes dans la sphère a fait pas
parce qu'il ya un plan d'eau oklad su
vous vous seriez trompé il ya un plan de
référence et une mère vous avez vous
circulation oui mais oui pas trop mais
d'as il faut qu'on soit si la zone est à
faire
voulait conclure nous ne permettrons pas
de quoi qu'on va pas passer pour adapter
le beau robert un pont en plus grande
plan d'eau que nous ils ont ils l'ont
pas pris et qu'effectivement c'est un
appareil qui n'a pas donné satisfaction
ça a été un échec
je ne dis pas que le maire ait trompé là
il a saisi une occasion mais la coca
ions malheureusement n'était pas adapté
ses plats si je sais que des services
techniques
alors le nsa d'état pourrait répondre
cela simplement je voudrais que ce soit
qui mettrait dedans il faudra qu'il y
ait de double langage a dit ça pour
monsieur goût désir qui actuel élu à
marigot même s'il a démissionné en tant
qu'adjoint mais il est quand même manque
de la majorité municipale et des
lyonnais les deux de ces partis de la
majorité au sénat
il faut que les mammouths et cie vous
allez manger sinon le jeu il faut que
marie goûter qui nous écoutent sache
pour qu'ils aient voté en mars 2015 qui
est qui qui fait quoi quand j'entends
monsieur les yeux qui est toujours
conseil municipal parce que j'ai à
blâmer pour me renseigner vous faites
partie de la majorité mais on va pas
débattre longtemps les marocains vont
nous donner la réponse ne se fait pas
mais quand vous dites que l'obstruction
comme il faut qu'on ait accordé un petit
peu d'attention
c'est une abeille destiné à l'audace
mais vous conviendrez quand même si vous
laisser seulement peut soit vous êtes
tous les deux concernés super y compris
l'opposition dépenser autant d'argent
pour la matinée bon signe parce que les
impôts c'est pas simplement marigot
c'est tout montini je me dit vous savez
que c'est pour leur douce et vous
laissez faire l'acquisition d'un
matériel qui va de toute façon il est
derrière la mairie d'ailleurs j'ai fait
passer une vidéo pour les mammouths et
je vais encore la ramener cette vidéo ce
soir bocaly m'a écouté et j'ai bien dit
cent mille euros dans ma vidéo que vous
avez tous vu je mettais pas trompé
maintenant il faut qu'il ya un langage
clair pas avoir su rebondir il faut
aller à ces élections mais pas avec des
masques
même si nous sommes dans la période
carnavalesque mais pas de masque
il faut faire tomber les masques et que
du marigot t3 conscient pour qui ils
vont décider de la prochaine mandature
mango moi je vais adresser si vous
permettez tout à l'heure je fais un
petit peu de jours
c'est en tgv il faut caler margotin soit
sûr de vous avez dressé la présence
élevée mais si on roule aux assauts si
vous associez monsieur gros désir les
autres vols ou d'appréciation peut-être
sûr parce qu'elle est à dire mais le bon
le bon choix sur l'outil la
machine-outil là mais qui est financé
par le sommet des il en fait partie
il a bien voté les crédits pour
permettre à monsieur le maire de valider
cet achat alors faut pas venir de se
présenter aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
s'est passé vous avez été mal conseillé
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas eu
suffisamment le temps de lire la notice
d'emploi de la machine outil qu'est ce
qui s'passe ans je dis très simplement
comme auch ne s'est pas trompé quand il
dit qu'on doit être solidaire surtout
quand on a fait partie de l'équipe
municipale
là j'avais dénoncé publiquement mon ami
daniel goudier vous dire que non jamais
et je tiens la fiche technique du
matériel à la disposition de toute la
population
jamais au grand jamais de l'anel cela
n'a été dit que ce soit une machine pour
le douce premièrement deuxièmement c'est
une machine entièrement en aluminium
donc vous comprenez bien que la fiche
technique est soumise à la rs al adl au
préfet enfin à tous les organismes qui
doivent intervenir pour que l'on puisse
dire qu on puisse se tromper à la longue
je peux l'accepter dans la mesure où il
fallait répondre à une urgence 12 en
urgence ont pas quoi comme jenny temps
oblige premium deuxièmement c'était une
occasion pour se faire financer à 90 %
par la commune n'intervient qu'à hauteur
de 10 %
est ce que je voudrais dire et je
dénonce encore mon ami qui a été au
conseil municipal lorsque tout récemment
dans une pile et malgré le fait que les
démissionnaires est votre assise
ah non aucun produit lorsqu'un certain
margot thème de la margot tous les
jouets puy-de-dôme à sainte marie ils
ont fait sa joie mais en 2013 2015 non
remise à melgven il faut bien qu on
règle ça t'a fait attendre même
peut-être que si vous étiez plus près
des sargasses sera peut-être pas à ce
stade
aujourd'hui je faisais avant qu'on
entend dans un micro trottoir dans le ja
disait le problème de gestion de de 2,7
tout seul c'est qu' il fallait deux
trois ou quatre pilotes
pourquoi parce que l'air est ce nous
fait savoir qu'aucun employé ne peut
rester plus de deux heures dans les
sargasses donc si on veut d'une journée
de travail complète et bien on doit
mettre le personnel donc gia forme et
j'ai eu le temps de former 3 il fallait
quatre 4 x 2,8
donc les ifs à l'aide d'un équipement
exceptionnel
donc aujourd'hui on peut se vanter de
toutes sortes de choses ou encore
critiqué le maire là dessus je le redis
à peut-être qu'à partir du 15 mars
ils seront mère et ils verront comment
gérer cette affaire c'est au pied du mur
en tant qu on voit les terminaux cette
séquence on en abandonnant notamment
pris non voulait répondre alors facile
allez-y non nous avons eu une discussion
sur ce cet appareil
le service technique a dit que
l'appareil nepad à petit ça a été un
petit peu sulfureux d'accord demain même
s'est énervé et on a même et discuter
pour pouvoir dire qu'on va revoir
l'histoire d'autant plus que c'est d'y
et le service technique est intervenu
lors d'un bain d'une réunion publique
qu'ils aient service technique
intervient qu'il conseillerait qui
concerne les autres qu'ils connaissent
et qui concernait le lacet de la
sécurité alors ce que je vous dis là je
vous le dis monsieur pirates vous a
présenté un plan de financement
un plan de financement qui n'est pas de
se désoler le résultat parce que on a dû
faire une modification budgétaire pour
trouver 40000 euros pour pouvoir
compléter les
et 55 pouces en a deux de résultats donc
se multiplient pour cent alors les
effets que la personnalisation de la
ville s'est lui élevé que celui qu'une
sans tache indiqués par ces
développements sont 100 et j'ai terminé
pour le nom je réponds vous dire tout de
suite que c'est encore du faux dans la
mesure où je vais quand même faire une
révélation
jusqu'à ce jour le tout sur n'a pas été
pays ni par la région ni part je sais
alors et hussein et non mes gars lui et
on peut dire non mais je sais pourquoi
je parle de plan de financement
le plan de financement le succès de la
modification budgétaire aussi c'était
une modification du ce pour modifier le
plan de financement
et c'est pas parce que le plan de
financement a été établi que c'est déjà
payé nous avons eu d'autres
d'autres événements qui ont été payées 1
après donc sais je sais je vous remercie
de l'est et genève de la voix dit
puisqu'il a dit je ne veux pas 10 parce
que c'est vrai que ça allait rejoindre
alors promise attendent maintenant les
propos de quelques marigot tinée et
marie goater rencontrer aujourd'hui même
par christine cuppitt alors elle ne
s'est pas rendu comme on le fait souvent
dans le bourg mais elle est allée dans
les chemins de traverse dans la campagne
à rigaud tine donc voilà
écoutez et puis jean-marc partie vous
fera réagir ensuite bien sauf qu'il
manque des transports on peut pas aller
partout surtout à dominante puisque les
transports ils sont assez chers et puis
l'activité aussi surtout il manque des
activités très mort il ya deux trois
activités mis en a pas assez pour
éveiller les jeunes améliore la jeunesse
le sport je suis de l'activité et
l'animation si on a le terrain qui
habille mais on a le gymnase qui est un
petit peu abîmés aussi je pense que ça
va venir pour les travaux mais ouais les
infrastructures pour permettre aux
jeunes de s'épanouir on ne te pouvoir
trouver leur voie
parce qu'en ce moment on sent que son
petit peu perdues le hand le basket
c'est pas ça le foot aussi c'est pas ça
non plus ça imac
on sent qu'il manque un petit peu un
petit qu'un petit quelque chose
l'alcool et la drogue c'est ce qui mène
la cesci tuer puis de mettre des études
de sport chez les jeunes du mail
beaucoup le sport qu'on puisse le
marigot plus élevé est beaucoup plus de
petits jury jouer j'étais bien et puis
ça tombe bien là j'ai pas pourquoi
voilà donc quelques éléments sur la
valeur de sondage nous sommes d'accord
c'est simplement les avis et les
ressentis de quelques personnes nées
marigot rencontré ce matin même je
l'amenais rumeur du marigot est-ce que
ça correspond à ce que vous voyez ce que
vous attendez vraiment si c'est très
clair que la situation s'est dégradée
c'est dire à des tas dire que on était
parti avant électorale 2014
l'immobilisme
puis le nouveau maire entre la critique
a critiqué votre wii immense crise et
puis il a embrayé en marche arrière puis
la situer
c'est catastrophique c'est bien pour ça
que le mou d'autres dansaient c'est
arrêter le massacre
aujourd'hui monsieur wade à ce qu'ils me
disent l'association il sait bien la
subvention de 2010 n'a pas été assez
n'est déjà pas importante
elle n'a pas été versé pour 2010
c'est plein de choses comme ça sur
lesquels nous reviendrons parce que on
fait de m'as-tu-vu du paraître de
l'agitation n'est ce pas de la
gesticulation
en réalité rien ne se fait on a voté des
plans de financement enfin rien rien n'a
été fait au cours des six dernières
années
quand je dis rien évidemment je suis
peut-être excessif mais nous avons parlé
de sa façon de parler mais parce que
compte tenu de ce qui devrait se faire
ce qui s'y fait qui a obligation de
faire en réalité quand on dit par
exemple n'a changé le parc automobile
c'est comme si on nous disait qu'on
avait payé les personnels tous les mois
le parc automobile de la gombe de la
commune ces deux cd chose obligatoire
parce que c'est nécessaire c'est des
outils dry donc par conséquent elle des
raisons qu'on évoque qui ne sont pas
recevables
je sais je sais tu bien placé pour
savoir que les finances publiques sont
d'une façon générale extrêmement fragile
il faut pas qu'on raconte via de
l'argent j'avais le choix il faut aller
le chercher il suffit d'aller le
chercher je ne vois rien venir
donc on est en marche arrière on a
beaucoup régressé et c'est dommage pour
la ville de marine alors j'ai pas très
bien ces mêmes questions quelles sont
vos réactions ce que vous avez sur les
rentables alors qu en entendant les
margotton les quelques échos que vous
avez je me dire ce qu'ils étaient à ma
réunion dédiée soir à fond dominique
c'est exactement ce qui se passe à mag
on n'est pas là pour aller d'or
des formes de polémique qui ne feront
pas progresser le marigot ce que je veux
dire aux mariou tant est qu'ils en
soient conscients il ya eu un échange
antoine monsieur perez et monsieur goût
désir c'est l'ambiance qui règne au
conseil municipal
il va falloir qu'on y mette un terme
définitivement en morse 2020 mois par il
ya de la zizanie et à la zizanie et puis
c'est pas sérieux parce que moi mais je
me connais je suis un homme de parole
quand je dis quelque chose je le fais et
si on arrive à certaines situations marc
godin je le dis à mon ami dernier go
désir en 2004 j'ai vu monsieur perez au
deuxième tour mais je lui ai dit il à
gagner qu'il y aille je lis m'a rien
proposé
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas accepté je
n'aurais pas accepté qu'il fasse son
équipe et demain on n'a pas venir se
plaindre en 2008 fable un petit peu
enfin peu d'histoire où les jeunes qui
vont voter il faut qu'ils sachent à
margaux l'histoire politique de marigot
en 2008 je faisais partie de la majorité
avec l'ancien maire ici de façon il
porte bien son nom l'ancien maire de
marigot ben moi jorge laverde oui
l'ancien maire je dis bien
eh bien écoutez j'ai pas fait de hausse
comme j'ai pas fait polémique je lui ai
dit que je me représentais pas mais je
suis allé jusqu'au bout de madame
mandature et c'est simplement ça il faut
donner des choses qu'il faut dire des
choses claires à la population
maintenant pour revenir à mon projet
parce que je suis ici comme un point
parle quand j'écoute les gens mais je
les dis et je le répète il va voir le
recours au juge si les margotin ça c'est
ma boussole le peuple marie boutin
je plaide depuis 2004 j'étais moi-même
transporter tout le monde le sait c'est
pas ici qu'on va me faire de leçon
j'ai les hommes de mai je fonctionne
avec un département de personnes âgées
l'essayons je vous dis le marigot quoi
moins de 22 kilomètres carrés écoutez
pour sortir de papin aléas gandega à vol
d'oiseau ya pas deux minutes mais j'en
prends l'exemple de mes parents qui sont
malins et qu'ils voulaient aller voir
une scène qui se trouve à demander mais
c'est pas possible
ne parlons pas de diarra ne parle pas de
plate forme et bien moi je dis camargo
nos projets la chose la plus urgente est
vrai que c'est une jeune qui en parle 1
s'est établi un petit système de
transport ma la taille de la commune
je vous dis il ya des partenaires et à
la santé et à cap nord même si ça fait
partie monsieur le maire vous y êtes
2 cd comment dire c'est compétences
résister compétences mais facultative 1
mais j'en vois que c'est au maire de
donner l'impulsion d'heure monsieur
perez dans son programme en avait parlé
aussi mais ils n'avaient le rouage
d'aller jusqu'au bout par contre partie
que j'ai déjà dit oui avec l'alliance
nouvelle c'est un projet est important
pour nous maintenant concernant de l'an
prochain parce que le temps passe vite
vous avez déjà réagi à des hauteurs va
passer mais vous vous avez dit que vous
proposez un système de transport inter
quartiers depuis des terminaux par
rapport aux think i qui a sauvé notre
temps on apprend dans le maire refuse à
dire vos désirs ce que vous avez entendu
mercredi noir ce que vous vivez où il
est jeune on parlait de choses simples
en dedans c'est à dire l'attractivité de
la commune il ya le problème des faux
structure n'a en gros problème de la
structure et ça date pas d'aujourd'hui
qu'on a ce problème des factures et
monsieur et l'avenir et quand il est
arrivé avec déjà ce problème de la
défense fructueux il est quand même
aussi du neuf on n'a rien fait là dessus
donc le stade ça c'est plus empirique
autres qu'autre chose on n'a jamais eu
de scandale qui avait la possibilité de
faire un stade moi j'étais président
l'association moi j'ai su présidents des
deux présidents d'as une association que
moi même j'ai participé à la création
et c'est cette association qui a le plus
de titres au niveau de sa place en
association
c'est dominante qui a le plus de titres
au niveau de la martinique et je vous
dis moi j'ai traité directement avec le
maire du lot 1 pour pouvoir avoir accès
à des infrastructures que ça soit des
gymnases du loing ou des terrains
externe pour pouvoir pour pouvoir s'y
par la période médiane en place comment
donc et que et que j'ai dû traiter
directement et pourtant j'ai fait appel
à un
la municipalité qui n'a jamais réagi
donc on à la situation un fax ou tuer
est comme ça et que moi je dis quand je
suis arrivé en 2014 j'ai proposé
directement à monsieur peyras
l'établissement d'un terrain de handball
dans la cour de l'école de dominante
pour ça nous allait nous permettre de de
fermer des usines et des gymnases pour
réhabiliter ce gymnase alors que ça n'a
pas été fait vous êtes un déçu de
monsieur perrin oui parce que je suis
assez déçu séduirait suzuki non mais je
suis déçu de la nature il ne sait pas ce
que moi si vous parlez des 100
propositions et quant au transport des
transports il est une compétence d'un de
la cité m ce spa faut absolument
par contre il faudra que la municipalité
en place fasse une proposition à la ctn
et c'est ce que nous allons faire
attention comme celui-là micro trottoir
je rappelle juste que le transport en
martinique est de la compétence de vente
l'écrasement et non pas de la cité m
messieurs
c'est ce que je voudrais simplement dire
aux administrés du marigot faites
attention aux discours qui seront tenues
le transport c'est sous l'autorité de la
cdm joseph peyras mère du marié
patrick bédard mère du marigot daniel
goudey sur mer du marigot ange lavenaire
je peux pas en parler parce que bon il a
été maire nous allons les plans
courjault de 0,6 il peut leur côté doit
il pour qu'il se pose a priori dans
l'avenir mais dites moi aucun oui mais
au delà c'est mr oui aucun de ces mères
ne pourra s'occuper ou encore organiser
le transport aux marines une question
des missions à ne pas organiser mais est
ce que la ville peut faire des
propositions et nous on était jeunes et
même de l'organisation je sais ce que je
veux dire je vais même vous donner une
proposition qui a été faite par la ville
d'umm al gore cap nord c'est à dire
maintenant s'est dotée de deux bus de
bus où on confiait à des communes un
usage de 2,2
woods ou des deux bus pendant une
certaine période pour les administrés
qui ont des difficultés de se rendre
d'un quartier à un autre et bien ce
projet comme le marigot a fait sa
demande
eh bien on apporte l analyse sur le fait
que déjà les transporteurs qui sont sur
place n'ont même pas la possibilité de
gagner leur pain ont valeur encore leur
enlever du pain puisque ce sera du
transport gratuit
alors il y a un choix à faire est ce
qu'on pense à l'économie ou est ce qu'on
a le temps leur spacieux laverty dit oui
allez y messieurs vous dire que mr c'est
un travail de spécialistes généralistes
que c'est vrai qu'on peut aimer le sport
présidente de l'association et vouloir
tout le sport c'est impossible
deuxième chose monsieur legault désir a
peut-être la mémoire courte je veux lui
rappeler nous avions fait un grand
emprunt terrain de handball du cernon au
nom vous avez massacré le stade voudrait
matin que vous avez fait intéressant
consulter personne qui n'était pas aux
normes
vous l'avez fait part que vous avez vous
quand vous avez fait les les vos études
vos devis vous avez pu le moins cher et
ça a explosé
au bout de six mois on ne sait pas non
mais cela rennais mais ne racontez pas
des choses qui sont pas examinés avaient
corrigé ce soit vous dites vrai nom là
bref c'est tout ce qu'on dit est vrai
j'aimerais moi je dis n'est pas vrai
c'était pas que nous avons fait nous
avons fait un terrain de handball et
alep en souvenez vous vous me disiez il
faut couvrir à lévis jamais moindre
enfin on va passer la parole de l'homme
et non le terrain de football qui est en
mauvais état si il était parti en 2011
on la refait on la refait totalement on
a dépassé ces 100 millions à l'époque
pas revenir sur votre parcours nature là
mais je ne peux pas le laisser
non mais quand même dire dans les choses
vous avez corriger voilà j'ai couché
s'est ouverte jeudi
mais évidemment vers leurs dettes alors
j'aime bien vouloir l'aider revenir bien
on sent bien de quel côté souffle
cela veut dire bien maintenant c'est
omaha goûtez donc le choix sans
prétention je le dis bien sans
prétention mais on va pas ressasser le
passé le marigot a besoin d'avancer
moi je suis pas d'accord monsieur le
maire sous une partie de votre réflexion
sachant pertinemment que les choses ne
sont pas faciles ça tout le monde le
sait en martinique est peut-être un peu
plus à margaux puisque nous sommes une
petite commune mais la raison n'est pas
là pour sacrifier les gens du margaux
non plus sur l'autel de jeunes ce qui
est pas c'est pas possible parce que
carnot à dire il ya une volonté
politique dans tout je vois les choses
évoluent au loin et on redémarre a dit
que c'est pas possible non mais quand on
essaye et je me dis c'est là ici c'est
peut-être là la télé c'est monsieur le
maire vous vous je vous dis je vous le
dis avec beaucoup de respect vous le
savez c'est foutrement de proximité je
pense et la réalité du terrain
moi j'ai fait le choix de travailler à
marie gauche par le matin je dépose du
monde
je revois mon père me dit j'en ai
entendu monde je revois décembre mon
repas et encore du monde mais faut faut
qu'on trouve une solution et les gens
vous l'ont dit c'est pas patrick benes
maintenant pour avancer sous le marigot
toujours je veux dire dans ce cas nous
proposons marigot parce que nous sommes
pas là je n'ai pas critiquer en
permanence comme ça se fait entre les
gens qui sont au conseil municipal dont
il va il va falloir y mettre de l'eau je
dis simplement qu'on margotin si vous
nous permettez d'être aux affaires 2020
ce que l'on proposé des choses simples
et bien la dimension de la com et je
répète à chaque fois là la même chose
écoutez oui mais attendez vous aurez
voulions développer puisque le dernier
j'avais presque 10 millions et s'est
consacré à sa justement fait donc il
faut que les autres puissent s'exprimer
jusqu'à l'autre thème avant que vous
fassiez vos conclusions
c'est justement comment développer
comment améliorer l'attractivité
wii passe de cette ville à l'est du
marigot est une commune va sans tain
c'est ça la géographie qu'il impose
entre sainte marie et laurent
l'extrême nord qu'est-ce qui peut
arrêter le visiteur qui peut être
touriste ou alors retenir le marigot et
mma rigotti n'y a pas d'hôtel il ya de
bons restaurants c'est vrai mais ça me
suffit peut-être pas à fixer une
population a attiré 1 5 million
d'ailleurs vous le savez que vous savez
quoi ce torrent ah ben oui mais voilà
donc la question qu'un faudrait-il faire
pour le monde la commune plus attractif
non seulement pour les visiteurs pour
les autres partis mais pour les gens des
marigots mêmes qui ont tendance à partir
vers cette marie trinité où la région de
foyers d égaliser allons donc
premièrement il faut retenir un chiffre
un type qui très important de 2013 a
aujourd'hui nous avons perdu plus de 450
habitants et qu' on ne peut pas me dire
que c'est des gens qui partent en dehors
de la martinique ça vous avez dit ça
fait et 0,7
moi j'avais compté 0,5 en moyenne donc
pour ça veut dire que nous on perd
chaque année en plus de 2 % de nos
habitants c'est en 5 10 ans on sera à
2506 et je dis souvent que ce soit quand
on habite dans le quartier du marigot on
verra même plus boisé l'activité de
cette commune de se faire de deux façons
premièrement l'attractivité économique
nous pouvons nous avons la possibilité
puisque nous avons raté la première la
première séquence sa dot céder les zones
rurales hôpitalisation rural qui avait
été votée dans 97 et dont le marigot
était était de l'une des douze communes
ou qui pouvaient qui pouvaient en
bénéficier
voilà on n'a pas trouvé un élu pour
pouvoir jeter les yeux dessus pour
pouvoir non désignés là dessus le plan a
été modifié et c'est la zone fin
d'activités nouvelles
nouvelle génération qui a été votée en
demain 2019 et qui permet à tous ceux
qui s installe au niveau de la commune
des petites entreprises etc de
bénéficier de 50 à 100% d'exonération
d'impôts pendant très longtemps
il faudra absolument que nous écrivons
nous venge donc que vous êtes une zone
franche de frank g d'une fois ce qui est
un peu qu'importe en difficulté
particulière revient à l'heure où
l'élève les autres collégiens les
outre-mer et les autres honneurs et les
zones où ira la maisonnée et que donc il
faut absolument que nous fassions est
entré et l'allée la commune là dedans
pour que nous puissions bénéficier de
ces petites heures assis là où le
premier point que je dois enlever
audition oui parce ce que vous étiez
déjà parti je vois projet vous vous
vivez au marigot vous y travaillez
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire d'après
vous qu'est ce que la mairie peut faire
parce que la mairie ne peut pas tout
faire le maire de brax touchèrent
évidemment mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut
bien qu'un pulsé pour rendre la commune
un peu plus dynamique
alors c'est une évidence il manque
d'animation malo alors peut-être que
dans votre micro trottoir n'ai pas eu le
temps non quand ils suffisamment terre
c'est vrai j'ai la chance et le
privilège de présider une association et
monsieur toul et l'ancien maire comme le
nouveau maire ou monsieur goût désir
nous avons eu l'occasion de travailler
ensemble peut vous dire qu'en matière
d'animation franchement je n'ai pas à me
vanter mais c'est une réalité
et comme je le dis en deux buts propos
nous sommes un petit peu gêné dans cette
manne est dans notre progression par
rapport aux sagas est si vrai que ça
faisait quelques problèmes mais
maintenant pour la nema il faut de
l'animation quand on dit que les jeunes
pas il faut de l'animation mais pour les
obtenir
moi j'ai initié pas mal de 2,2
d'opérations sous le marigot tels que le
lombez chaunac
on a essayé de faire la queue partie
sous le capot attirer du monde pour
mettre en évidence les talents du
marigot le carnaval à margaux dont je
profite de l'occasion pour guillaume
goutay qui vont être en croire une
nouvelle fois privé d'animation puisque
monsieur le maire m'a envoyé son
courrier pour me dire que là qu'ils
voient pas du carnaval à marigot et tout
le monde sait que notre association un
département tant pour les seniors mais
aussi pour l'animation on est en groupe
à pied qui s'appelle groupes différents
la riaa nous essayons d'animer les
quartiers et ce qui me peine ce qui me
touche franchement
sous la cendre en matinée on à la ville
de fort de france le lamantin c'est pire
nous allons voeckler demain soir nous
avons unité qui nous voient comment dont
les contrats sont signés et je vous dis
du fond du coeur margotin c'est vrai on
pourra rien faire et margot simplement
je sais pas ce qui se passe monsieur le
maire nous le dira j'ai été ce même
peut-être que monsieur d'être monsieur
n'est pas tout comme evans oui mais
c'est pas ça non il n'aime pas mais je
dis à chaque fois et j'ai l'exemple et
jeudi au margutti et je le dis à
monsieur le maire aussi le maire en
place vous qu'il ait pas de confusion
j'ai connu en 2014 cet épisode aussi un
ancien maire qui était là et qui a pensé
privé patrick geddes de quelque chose à
punir la population pour le carnaval
j'espère de tout coeur mais sur le
jardin de monsieur l'afnor je ne veux
pas désigner le margotin le savent j'ai
fait à quoi monsieur le maire ici en
place l'a fait parce qu'il ya pas
d'argent je n'en sais rien il est assez
grave a eu beau mais jeudi omar goûter à
noël on a été privé de guillaume à noël
il n'y a pas eu grand chose qu'en aval
c'est fini
comme le dit notre ami du margaux
montcoy y ont plongé nos magasins même
le plancher drago vraiment dans le noir
ou le reste 10 minutes d'émission et
vous êtes très en avance que cette
affaire mais je préfère terminer comme
ça et je fais ma conclusion mélodie on a
un côté de trêve est hâtif et je ne vais
pas me substituer à la mairie pour
organiser le carnaval
je ne suis pas encore maire de margaux
un peu de patience et si c'est leur
choix
nous allons reprendre comme gaza fois la
noël comme surface va conclure tout à
fait c'est vous qui aurez donc en
dernier la conclusion va donner la
parole ange lavenaire ensuite
ou alors allez-y et puis monsieur
l'avenir alors allez-y c'est bien ce que
je voulais faire excuser moi ou à
l'asile à la question terry sur
l'attractivité 40 pour la commune plus
dynamiques sur le plan économique social
culturel
non je pense là encore coup se trouve
tout on parle d'attractivité on ne parle
pas de spectacle et cetera dans l'es8
l'attractivité c'est
trouver un moyen pour animer la ville
mais je parle bien en termes de
développement économique
car qu'est-ce qui fait rester un peuple
dans sa ville c'est d'abord parce qu'ils
y trouvent du boulot parce qu'ils y
trouvent un moyen dû réaliser une
résidence et aussi parce qu'ils trouvent
un moyen pour la scolarité des enfants
enfin il y à des équipements qu'une
ville droit se douter tout hâtives et
les gens des communes voisines pour
obtenir la populace le cas aujourd'hui
alors le cac est en train de se
présenter puisque depuis trois ans j'ai
confié à cattenom l'étude d'une aide à
une zone d'aménagement économique pour
les marigots tinqueux auquel je
m'adresse à la pointe
mais le projet il écouter benoît
supermarché mais seulement non non il
n'y sera pas mais ya pas de supermarché
peu de prévu ça c'est encore de la force
mais je sais pour les mâles il nous
reste une démission alors beaucoup
d'envié et là où je dis qu'il y à de la
désinformation une volonté de
désinformation dans la mesure où des 98
et 2000 de 10,90 de dettes 2008 2018 et
2019 aux différentes fêtes patronales
le maire et le conseil municipal ont
présenté ses projets donc on n'a pas
entendu qu'il y ait des élections
puisqu'un projet se construit sur ce
monde sur moins trois ou quatre ans j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les
différents candidats qui pourtant et
c'est là où ça m'attriste os concluant
oui qui pourtant sont des anciens élus
car il n'y a pas de novices l'haïtien
nous avons un ancien maire nous avons un
adjoint 13 ans adjoint de la ville nous
avons un autre adjoint six ans adjoint
de la ville donc des gens qui
connaissent la gestion publique alors
qui aujourd'hui veulent dire à ce mr et
bien ce que nous n'avons pas fait en 20
ans il faut que vous le fassiez en six
ans
non j'ai dit non et je souhaite une
deuxième mandature pour terminer le
travail que j'ai commencé je l'avenir
paraît qu'une question avant la
conclusion de l'émission ainsi joseph
perez ne soyez pas triste
pas encore en tout cas simplement
s'agissant de l'attractivité c'est vrai
que ça ne peut pas se parler à margaux
comme ça se parle mais la forme de
france c'est compliqué même à fort de
france c'est compliqué faut des moyens
et puis il faut de l'animation en
permanence maintenant on peut pas parler
de communes sur papa d'intercommunalité
oui et vous êtes bien placé je veux
rappeler ici que le développement
économique c'est de la responsabilité de
la compétence de cap nau mais c'est bien
qu'non qui travaillent sur le projet du
marigot
alors je dis qu'au tour et ne conteste
pajot complète
alors on a bien complété du tout vous
tentez de parler mais c'est la loi
d'yverdon aujourd'hui aux propos ce que
j'avais commencé avec une équipe à la
cap nord
c'était la revitalisation du
centre-ville commencés par les dix
espaces qu'on ne puisse occuper
librement en toute sécurité
c'est chacun et téva mario commençant
par la place de l'église les venelles
qui conduisent
et puis ça s'est arrêté ouais parce que
j'étais battu chiche été battu si vous
êtes élu le marché ne seraient pas
cassés on aurait utilisé le marché qui
te bâtiment qu'on avait terminé de payer
en 2008
donc c'était un bâtiment solide ce
marché n'a pas été utilisé pendant 19
ans messieurs et dames
tu veux en venir allez-y nous avons
continué vous avez vous avez et croyez
moi car l'espace parce que je vois par
exemple la place de l'aide du marché où
les lampadaires rien ne marchait plus
l'ascension par occuper il faut
reprendre tout ça est déjà redonné puits
creusés les marchés
c'est ça qui donne les vendredis soir
monsieur brut est disert amont et comme
ils ne disent pas du tout parce que le
bichon
c'était une époque ça marchait bien
après on en parle pas des mêmes choses
j'ai fait
soyons sur ses chaînes animations women
10 convient pas du tout l'histoire est
là pour nous rappeler les faits mais
c'est ça n'a rien à voir et vous mais
j'ai testé sein d'une association j'ai
toujours voulu souvent voulu leur
garantir mais je n'y retourne pas tout
ça n'a pas marché pas du tout référence
à l'animation de la biche oh que vous
organisiez pas je suis d'accord mais je
n'avais aucun ensemble annonce à ses
partenaires n'ont pas d'heure je pense
ici à yopougon mais simplement pour dire
mais ces terres sont épiés celle à venir
féliciter monsieur bruit d'un foudres du
succès de notre la foule où tout vous
dire qu'une minute et puis on passe aux
conclusions dont je souffre pas encore
de cette pathologie
je pense que je pense qu'il y avait
matière à faire mais il faut
progressivement aller vers des
animations avec des associations parce
que il y a un vrai problème de restaurer
la confiance avec la population avec des
associations avec les fournisseurs de la
ville parce qu'il ya là vraiment une
espèce de fracture et nous avons en
pointe tout cela merci donc messieurs
ben voilà nous arrivons donc au terme de
ce débat est donc ce sera à chacun
d'entre vous de conclure en une minute
puisque le tirage au sort a désigné
monsieur joseph peraste pour conclure en
dernier en nous proposons donc à
monsieur patrick bredas d'entamer lui sa
conclusion en une minute une minute
alors j'ai dit à marie goater j'avais
entendu vous avez écouté en 2020 je
crois très sincèrement que le magot a
besoin de mères vivant et résidant dans
sa commune un mec ne sera dit pas des
listes électorales comme ça a été le cas
de monsieur peyras parce qu'il a eu deux
défaites
et puis qui se rapproche après du
marigot et qui voit partir à 102 dans
pas longtemps les margotin ont surtout
besoin de mer capables de changer de
rythme à tout moment ça c'est l'avenir
et surtout ils ont besoin de mer qui
répond à la proximité un maire qui prend
ses engagements et qu'il ne passe pas du
coq à l'âne du soir au lendemain et qui
crée la confusion dans sa commune
surtout un mais respectueux du choix des
yeux ça a été notre cas en 2014
nous l'acceptons en 2020 si le peuple
choisit aussi de faire autre chose nous
allons accepter ce choix démocratique et
nous disons que moi j'ai pris le temps
de lire l'histoire politique de margaux
on ne pourra pas l'incarnation on ne
croit pas au revenant en politique on
croit pas non plus aux illusionnistes
on en a souffert merci beaucoup margotin
à tout à l'heure merci patrick bidasses
daniel gros désir
oui donc j'ai demandé au mari gaudin de
faire confiance à notre liste ensemble
bâtissons notre avenir
parce que nous voulons développer la
proximité une gestion non pas verticale
mais horizontale fait sur et faire
confiance à la population pas les
conseils de quartier des conseils de
sages du conseil municipal des jeunes
une gestion tout près de la population
faire une grande confiance aux
associations qui sont pour nous des
poumons de la ville qui peuvent
permettre de changer la face actif de la
commune pour une animation en vraiment
je fais confiance reste à 5 secondes
les marigots d'un maxi et puis bonne
soirée à tous le monde
voilà en jeu l'avenir c'est votre tour
oui très simplement dit au marigot petit
déjeuner goûter que j'ai face à moi la
1ère qui a été soutenue par deux autres
candidats qui sont face à lui
aujourd'hui il est quand même assez
extraordinaire qu'on a dit de voter pour
quelqu'un lui maintenant qu'on vient de
dire de voter contre lui donc par
conséquent c'est un problème de
crédibilité et de constance en politique
de responsabilité et de netteté
politique que par conséquent votre
serviteur ange lavenaire lieu demandé de
revenir je reviens avec plaisir parce
que je sens qu'il faut remettre le my
world
vous avez conclu en moins d'une minute
joseph peraste oui merci je voudrais
très simplement dire que c'est vrai nous
arrivons bientôt au thème de notre
première mandature myvu fort et solide
et à mon équipe et moi
dès le début nous avions dès le début de
notre mandature nous l'avions annoncé
notre volonté première c'était
d'apporter du bien être à cette
population qui en avait tant besoin
je dirais que nous n'avons pas démérité
et que nous pensons que la population
continuera à nous faire confiance et
acceptera de la renouveler cette
confiance en nous maintenant la
direction des affaires de la ville pour
une nouvelle mandature
car à notre humble avis une mandature ne
peut suffire
la première mandature ça permet n'est ce
pas au maire de premièrement montée
élaborer des projets obtenus et les
garanties de réalisation de ces projets
est ce le cas aujourd'hui quand tous les
projets que nous avons et que nous avons
présentées lors des fêtes patronales ou
lors des réunions de bilan à la
population tous ces projets sont là sont
financés qui attendent simplement que
les premiers fonds se débloque c'est à
dire les fonds de la commune que nous
n'avons pas une fois ces fonds c'est
super six ans et dix places conçue peut
rester bien qu' il faut être débloqués
donc nous sommes là et nous allons
encore couchés notre travail de
développement de la ville du marigot
je vous remercie à la merci messieurs
moi je vous dis au revoir et jean-marc
parti va vous préciser quelques
rendez-vous encore politiques à venir
pour la semaine prochaine
voilà un rappela que la réalisation de
l'émission était due à ses deux buts
inscrits avec la vente six patients
technique de corinne joseph pour leurs
chronos métrage et la participation
d'alain livory pour la préparation de
cette émission ce débat est à retrouver
sur internet 1 sur notre site internet m
la première martinique la première point
fr je répète martinique la première
point fr le prochain débat radio aura
lieu ce lundi
lundi 27 avec les candidats du
morne-rouge mardi 28 le lendemain sera
en télé avec le candidat du françois et
puis le prochain débat en radio et sur
internet
vendredi prochain
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir ce
sera avec ceux de rivière-pilote madame
monsieur merci de nous avoir écoutés
à bientôt élections municipales le débat
[Musique]